we're in florida
we talked about desantis we talked about
the nba bubble
what's this weekend it's superb mario
who do you got tell us
who should we be betting god uh-oh i
don't bet against goats
so wow well we got this straight up we
got the real goat versus the baby
tom brady so you're saying brady's going
to win it
yes so tampa base you're going to put
brady against my homes
yes okay young buck a lesson you think
so
that'll be twice he lost in the playoffs
by the way you're gonna paul what are
you saying yeah
uh i'm rooting for by the way paul
actually
no sports paul actually knows big time
i'm rooting for the buccaneers i think
they have a puncher's chance
but the chiefs are the better and more
consistent team
did you hear about the whole culvert
thing with the chiefs yeah no the barber
got covered and he cut 20 guys here and
they all do you know the players have to
test negative five days in a row to play
on five days ago pat mahomes got the
haircut with the barber as well
unbelievable yeah that's pretty crazy if
you lose because of a barber
i mean not barbara i mean the guys from
vegas are gonna go
find this barber you're gonna say damn
it you cost me 20 million bucks
i think they would push the super bowl i
think there was zero chance they would
oh really bro the super bowl is being
played in tampa this weekend i don't
know what's going on
if half of the chiefs are out they're
going to push the super bowl
by the way who else has said what you
just said right now uh
probably no one i don't know i've never
they're not gonna push the super bowl no
you can't you can't phys if you lose
half your team
because it's not like a replacement
buddy that's your responsibility you
should have followed the guidelines and
being a little bit more responsible
i get that part but you can't you can't
play the super bowl with half your team
and and what you you can't just say it's
a tie or
do you understand the amount of
preparation they've put into having the
freaking super bowl three days from now
i get it but
like everything all the sports league
about flexibility that's not what you
put in your bench i mean then now we
have like no you don't have a million
players
the super bowl is going to be this
weekend you will lose listen
i've been drawing you will lose so
so eric you got anybody or nobody okay
sam you got anybody or nobody who
bucks yeah who do you have paul you said
the chiefs cheese but i'm rooting for
the box okay who you got well i'm gonna
use your words
to prove my point here what's that okay
uh tom beardy's the goat
yeah patrick mahomes the baby girl
patrick mahomes they're they're the
favorite kfc's favorite minus three yeah
we talked about odds
patrick mahomes what do you do this past
offseason he signed a new
500 million dollar extension
right half a billion bucks almost
whatever it was biggest ever
here's i'm going to use give me a guy
with experience
for the guy with money the guy with the
money is going to walk with experience
the guy with experience is going to walk
away cut the bucks
i'm gonna i'm rooting for the bucks tom
brady that's my guy i've been rooting
in college i skirted by by running book
and i took uh
tom brady's first super bowl 2001
patriots were plus 14 points
this is obviously under the bill of
belichick era they beat the rams the
greatest show on turf
so i haven't gone against by the way
okay let me ask you if you're watching
this
push thumbs up if you got the bucks push
thumbs down if you got the chiefs i'm
actually curious
push thumbs
i won't because that's how i can track
it i see right now 795 to seven so if i
see this i'm look buddy right here okay
so 7.95 just okay so more people think
the bucks are going to win really
i think everybody's just rooting for tom
brady but if you actually look
at the logistics this is going to come
down to pass rush
whoever gets the generates more of a
passer is going to win this all right
there matt millen this guy
this guy's going deep over yeah well
look at the nfc championship game though
another concern
tom brady is throwing is having a lot of
turnovers right now
we all know our community ain't come
here for the sports pat give us your
prediction
pat mahomes patrick bet david who you
got
let me let me give you if both happens
let me give you if both happens i'll
kind of give it to you from
a different way if mahomes wins
that's like kobe always wanted to face
lebron in the playoffs
yeah you know kobe if kobe goes into the
finals
if kobe is jordan if kobe goes against
in the finals against jordan and beats
the bulls yeah
there's always that argument yeah okay
the the reason why lebron for the rest
of his
life is going to have the argument of
you're not the greatest
is because you know six lebron
oh you're jordan six championships six
for six all this stuff
there is moments in history that you
have to really capitalize
this may be mahomes most important game
of his lifetime for legacy purely for
legacy
because if mahomes beats i just got the
chills if mahomes beats
brady yeah the chances of brady going
back to the super bowl
slim to none at this point running it
back i'm not going to say something
i'ma say ten percent here's why who's
the most pissed off person in the world
this weekend
probably bill belichick no one's more
pissed off in the world than bill
belichick
nobody is more pissed off than bill
belichick you did this without me bro
he's got 60 million dollars to play with
he's gonna put a team together okay he's
about he's got a
60 million dollar who does salary
that's got opening to play with he is
going to put a team together that's
going to scare the hell out of everybody
belichick
belichick you don't give belichick 60
million dollar budget for you why does
he have 60 minutes he's got that's the
number he's got because he's camouflaged
salary capital salary caps he's got 60
million gotcha watch what this guy's
gonna come back with
which means what brady's the most hated
player as competitor
competitor because he keeps winning
nobody like nobody like jordan nobody
likes
as a company nobody like kobe everybody
like kobe when he retired and was
shooting 27 from the field oh we love
kobe yeah because he's not going to beat
you anymore you hated kobe 10 years ago
you love kobe now right
they still hate brady because he's still
in the super bowl oh yeah okay
uh if he beats brady fast forward 10
years from all the stephen a schmitz and
max kellerman's and skip bayless they're
all debating on tv under garcia
but the last time brady went to super
bowl he lost two patent homes
yeah and that's why pat mahomes is now
the goat because he beat the prior goat
and brady has to sit there for the rest
of his life listening to those
interviews
so for mahomes lots of pressure for
brady
a lot of pressure because brady knows
mahomes can take it away from him
so they both have a lot of pressure a
ton
my prediction here's my prediction
whoever gets sacked
two times in the first quarter loses
okay
whoever gets sacked two times in the
first quarter loses the super bowl
very simple if brady gets sacked twice
in the first quarter he's gonna lose
if mahomes get sacked two times on the
first quarter he loses what's your
what's your analogy you gotta shake the
guy up because there's
so much pressure shake them up sack them
twice
in the first quarter then you have a
shot okay
i think that's my prediction i may be
wrong mario were you trying to say
something this time
yeah that that that'd be my prediction
so give us a final score let's do it
i uh i don't know i think uh you know uh
last week when brady won tampa bay had a
solid defense so i'm
you know you know kc so i'm kind of a
i'm going tampa based defense believe it
or not i'm going tampa based defense
wins the championship
that's my bet so uh i could be wrong you
know
that my bet is tampa based defense going
to win the super bowl so
again uh i hope you're right pat i hope
you're right
as well but you better respect this
mahomes kid
he's likable he's crazy he's a great
teammate they
love him he's a good captain he's a good
face of the league in every possible way
the nfl got so lucky having them homes
so lucky to have them homes because the
nba the nfl is locked in the next 10
years
just because they have a good face right
mahomes is such a great face for the
league
so if he wins i won't be upset but i'd
like to see
my prediction is tampa based defense
gonna win this thing paul
how far is uh tampa bay from here asking
for a friend
probably uh you know less than four
hours three hours away
yeah all right so with the last thing by
the way uh let me let me do one more
here to see if the odds changed or not
uh yeah it's still people are saying
brady's gonna win hey if you enjoyed
today's podcast smash that subscribe
we're back
we're back we are back so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye